(upbeat music)
- I just wanted to say a few things.
Certainly for me, this has
been an amazing afternoon,
and I really wanna thank all the speakers
for brilliant talks,
most of which I could understand.
You know, we've heard
about brain circuits,
how experience can change these circuits,
leading to changes in behavior,
both during normal development
and also when development goes awry.
And we heard a number of themes
that weave through the talks,
that have been weaving through the talks,
including sensitive
periods, critical periods.
We've heard something
about speech and language,
stress, parenting, abnormal
experience, the teen brain,
which is, we've learned,
not like any other brain.
Autism, schizophrenia, adaptation genes.
I thought it was really interesting
that Matt said that genes
are not fate, which is,
and we've learned something about that.
The idea that you could come
and take advantage of
the inherent plasticity
that remains in the brain,
even sometimes in diseased brains,
and engage that for
treatment or, you know,
for therapy, in a way.
And we actually heard that from April
in terms of being able
to maybe even predict
and maybe even intervene in behaviors
that have to do with learning
and audition and language.
But I think Terry, in a
way, already summarized
what's left of the big challenges.
Basically, we don't know anything.
It's a really fantastic
time to be a neuroscientist
and to be a clinical neuroscientist.
There are so many challenges that remain.
There are lots of tools
that are being built,
and I think, you know, even today,
what you heard from all of us as we spoke
is that there's this enormous gap
in the scales of knowledge
between what we know
about the human brain,
both in health and disease,
and the fact that we see that human brain
on a scale that, in many
ways, can give us hints,
but really can't tell
us much about mechanism.
And on the other side of the coin,
we see the mouse brain or animal models
and we see them, those brains,
at the level of molecules.
And the challenge is
really to get to the point
where we can bridge these gaps in scale.
And my dream, actually, would
be not just to understand
and see the neurons all
active in these circuits
as we saw in the science fiction pictures
that Terry showed us of the human brain
and also those real pictures
of the zebrafish brain,
but the challenge would be
that we actually get to see
all the synapses and what they're doing,
because that's where a lot
of the action is happening,
and that's another order of magnitude,
if you remember, in Terry's list
from molecules to circuits of behavior.
So I think with that, it's
time to have some questions
and hopefully some answers.
So, Terry, why don't you come
and start with the
first sets of questions.
- Okay.
So we got some really good questions,
and I'm gonna start
out with one for April.
So you should queue up here.
So, "Dear April."
(laughter)
Okay, "There are individuals
with great intelligence
"who may not be so acoustically sensitive,
"like deaf people."
- Right.
- "So are there other
stimuli that may be critical
"for development of
understanding and language?"
- Well, that's an excellent question,
and of course we know
that you don't need audition
to develop language, per se.
And I'm using that as a
way to get into language,
but we were just talking about
different sorts of mechanisms.
I'm actually a, on a
dissertation committee
for a young man at Gallaudet
who's studying basically the timing
of these sign language and
how it develops across time,
and I'm very interested in how,
I'm really more interested in timing,
as Terry was just talking about,
and how the inputs have to
come in in a particular order
in order to engage the areas of the brain
that are going to be developing language,
and we know from the
research in the deaf world
that it doesn't need to be auditory input.
There's also the idea that
there can be a lot of
coordination among the senses
as the child is developing.
If they're hearing and they
have their other senses,
we were just talking
about how do you look at
how input into one sense
affects all of the other
connections in the brain,
because we know that language
is extremely connected,
and that all of these different,
if you look at what's happening
in people who are deprived of one sense,
you see taking over
another part of the brain.
It'll repurpose it,
but there is also this
coordination that happens,
and we're very interested in
looking at how that happens.
- Great, thank you.
So the next question
is for Catherine Dulac.
"Does your work relate to changes
"from homicidal, genocidal behavior
"in people who have lived
previously at peace?"
- So I'm not really sure
how this applies to humans,
but I think genocide or
aggression in general,
different circuit, I think,
and in order that I have
not had time to discuss
and that I will discuss, I think,
in the private session tomorrow.
We actually have found set of neurons
that are responsible,
or at least involved,
in infant mediate aggression.
So the type of infanticidal behavior
that you've seen in mice.
Interestingly, these neurons are present
both in males and females,
and in males, these neurons
are active in virgin males
and then become silent.
And in females, these neurons are related
to the stress pathway,
which is very interesting,
because we know that stressed
animals, stressed females,
tend to cull their pups,
so it's very well-known
that females in nature,
when there's too many,
there are too many predators
or there are not enough food,
will kill their infants,
because basically they don't
want to spend resources
on nurturing infants that
have no chance to grow up.
Now, let me get back to humans.
There is no infanticidal behavior
in the same way as in these species.
I think part of it, evolutionarily
speaking, as I mentioned,
there is not the competition happening
between a dominant male and
all sort of subordinate male
that doesn't give access
to subordinate male.
In monogamous species, the male
and the female are together,
and both taking care of infants,
so there is no need for this aggression,
and in essence, you
can understand monogamy
as being the evolutionary
response to infanticide.
So one way to escape infanticide,
which is an enormous waste of resources,
is actually for a couple to stay together
and both nurturing infants.
Now, what is quite interesting, though,
is that there are two types of infanticide
that are observed in humans.
One is related to mental illness,
and I mentioned postpartum psychosis.
That's one of them, and
it's extremely rare.
And the other one is a
cultural infanticide.
It has been the case
in many, many cultures,
including European culture,
Asian culture, African culture,
that infant were killed for
one reason or the other,
and there even a book that
an undergraduate student
mentioned to me that describe infanticide
that was systematically practiced
in the northern of Japan
from I think the 16th century till 1950.
And that was just done
very systematically,
as soon as infant, as soon as a family
had more than two children,
and it was done in this
entire part of Japan,
and it was very well recorded
by the bureaucrat, et cetera,
and then it disappeared.
But this clearly has nothing
to do with aggression.
Now, relate to genocide
or aggression in general,
the neurons that we found
that seems to be involved
in premeditated aggression
are actually not activated
during other types of aggression.
So male-male aggression
or maternal aggression.
These tics are handled by
other type of neuronal segue.
So I hope I answer the question.
- Very nice, very nice, okay.
BJ Casey, this is your question.
If you choose to take it.
"Does prenatal maternal stress
"affect the developing fetal brain?"
- So I think in my presentation,
I was a postnatal chauvanist,
and focused only on
changes during that time.
But we know that earlier in development,
there are a number of
environmental factors
that can impact the fetal brain,
and so the answer would be yes.
And I could expand on that more
if there was a specific
place you wanted to go,
whoever asked that.
- [Audience Member] Cortisol.
- [Audience Members] Cortisol levels.
- Cortisol levels.
- [Audience Member] In the mother.
- In the...
- [Audience Member] Mother.
- In the mother, right.
- [Audience Member] Stress.
- Right.
So that can have an impact, too.
We haven't looked at
it in our own research.
We've looked at that more
at the level of the children
who were stressed by
growing up in the orphanage,
but there are a number of
factors that could impact.
- [Terry] What about drugs, alcohol?
- So alcohol can have
drastic effects on the,
there are a number of factors
that can impact the developing brain,
particularly fetal development,
which was why it was so
important for our studies
when were looking at the
stress of the orphanage
to have a model in which we could control
other environmental factors
and control other genetic factors
that are just impossible to do in a human
to sort of show the
role of this experience.
But of course it's not gonna
be experience or genetics,
we're far beyond that.
It is the case that these
are always interacting.
Experiences can turn on and
off genes and their expression,
and so that's very
important to keep in mind
in all of this work.
- Okay, very good.
Okay, here's a curveball for Jay Giedd.
Jay, where are you?
There, okay.
"My husband behaves like the
teenager that you describe.
(laughter)
"Is this a case of delayed adolescence?"
- You need to be patient.
I mean, I guess fundamentally,
the other question, you know, is delay bad
in term of kind of,
quote, "late bloomers"?
And particularly in education,
there's a very strong
bias, earlier is better.
Read early, you know, the
sooner you meet milestones,
the farther you'll go.
And that's actually
pretty weakly supported.
There's many examples, probably
in this room, even, as well,
of kind of tortoise-and-hare
type of phenomenon,
where the rules for child
prodigies is they do okay.
So actually we looked at prodigies
in the Hopkins Center for Talented Youth,
and they're not jobless
on the street and stuff,
but usually people catch up.
A few kind of notable examples.
But I think that there's very
entrenched in our culture,
you know, the husband
(speaks indistinctly)
sort of to get away from this notion
of earlier is always better,
you know, Tiger Woods, or those examples,
you know, they did great
things at very young ages,
but there's so many
exceptions to that rule
of people of high achievement
that weren't always meteoric,
they weren't always the top
of their grades all the time,
that people sometimes wandered a bit
before they engaged in their passion.
And I've been surprised in terms of
if we're looking at extremes,
like how often that is the case,
and that people tend to have
strengths and weaknesses
and the environment matters a lot.
But it's a more seriously
interesting question
for children of illnesses that,
as long as they're improving slightly,
you know, like how long should a parent
sort of be very encouraged
and hang in there,
even if the progress is slight.
And I think, clinically, a long time.
I mean, I think that that's
a good mentality to have,
is don't look at the calendar so much,
but, you know, is your child learning
and are they still progressing, you know,
are they moving toward independence.
Because that sort of time of no return
keeps getting extended.
It used to be, you know, like,
a child by five, and
they're gonna be a criminal
or a saint or, you know, kind of things,
that we keep seeing examples of that are,
the plasticity and the advantage,
I should have emphasized this again,
it's not enhanced during adolescence,
it's just still there.
The younger, I think,
it's not like there's
a surge in plasticity,
and it never, I think,
goes away completely,
but I think that for parents
and for spouses and stuff
that to look more in terms of,
is progress still being maintained.
But it's definitely a case.
Some people never grow up in terms of,
in terms of executive function and stuff,
they remain impulsive,
they are every bit
indistinguishable, almost,
and some young people are incredibly,
delayed gratification, you
know, forward thinking,
and that's really a big
part of the challenge.
There's so much individual variation.
So for a legal system to
try to use these metrics,
I think that's part of the
fun and to tell them, like,
what accounts for this huge variation,
and what can we do about it?
But even something as basic as puberty,
so adolescence starts in
biology, it starts at puberty,
it ends in societal
independent functioning.
But it's like eight to 15 is normal.
That's a bizarrely long range
for something that's a big deal
in your world and in your environment.
So I think there's so
many unanswered questions
about trajectories, but I think
that the fundamental
one is that, you know,
earlier isn't always better.
So I know that won't help
the marriage very much,
I have a feeling.
(laughter)
Earlier but, yeah, early on (mumbles).
- Okay, so this is a question for Carla.
"I was surprised to hear
"that there are these
immune molecules on neurons.
"Does this mean that the
activation of the immune system
"in the rest of the body
can affect the brain?"
- Oh, cool question.
Actually, I have a
question for Terry, too.
You can look at it.
Yeah, so both Beth Stevens and I
talked about kind of
new roles for molecules
that were really thought to
be exclusively functioning
in the immune system,
and I think this is
gonna be a major theme,
and what's really interesting is that,
so this immune molecule that we study,
and we study a few of them,
they're all located at synapses,
and they're made by the neurons.
So the first point is just that
the immune system doesn't
own these molecules.
They have to share with
the nervous system.
But the second point, which
I think is really exciting,
is that it means that the immune system
and the nervous system
have a common language.
So the immune system and immune cells
can actually interrogate
the neural synapse directly
because molecules that it recognizes
are at the neural synapse.
And I think this really
opens up a new world
about thinking about
how the nervous system
and the immune system interact,
and I think it's just the
beginning of that world.
- So here's a question
that doesn't have any specific person
that it's directed at,
but maybe anybody who wants
to field it can come up.
"What happens in the brain when
the Zika virus infects it?"
Good question.
Okay, Rusty is taking the bait, okay.
(laughter)
- So it turns out that the Zika virus
has an affinity for primitive cells,
so that it can infect neurons,
and the mechanism by which it does it,
we don't really understand,
but it kills the cells,
so it has a very high
affinity for periphery cells,
so even, it turns out, in adults,
and this was demonstrated
in a paper recently here
from some colleagues in,
at Scripps, I believe,
showed that even in the adult,
there's certain cells
that are still dividing,
and they're vulnerable to
the Zika virus as well,
so that's why you see
these articles coming out
that the virus can affect
older people as well,
not just the fetus.
It's very interesting.
- Okay, so the next question
has to do with mathematics.
"Most mathematicians and
theoretical physicists
"do their best work at a young age,
"less than 30 years.
"Why?"
I think this is a good
question for Terry Sejnowski.
(laughter)
It is true.
That, in mathematics,
that there is prodigies,
and these are people who can do things
that are at a very early age
that you would have expected somebody
with a lot more experience.
Well, the reason why you find that
in math and music and a
few other areas is that
in math, you don't need
a lot of experience,
about the real world, because
math is its own world,
and you can learn the
assumptions and the theorems,
and your brain absorbs it
because it's, you know,
in a prime state, in some cases,
still in a critical period.
We find these prodigies who are teenagers.
However, the converse isn't true,
which is that even if you're old,
you can make an important contribution.
(laughter)
And here's why.
I once saw a film called
Strangeness Minus Three,
and it was about the
discovery of omega minus,
which is an elementary particle
which has strangeness minus three.
And they were interviewing Yuval Ne'eman,
who was one of the Nobel
Prize winners, got the,
you know, for doing the theory,
and they asked him, they said,
"You know, you're in your late
30s when you did your work.
"Isn't that a little bit late
for a theoretical physicist?"
And he says, "No, no, no, no, no.
"I attribute it to the traffic in London."
And here's the story.
So he was working on general
relativity in Israel,
and wanted to do his postdoc
with someone in London
at Imperial.
But he was also an attache
at the Israeli embassy,
which was on the other side of the city.
So he realized this wasn't gonna work.
He was gonna be, he'd like
to be able to pop in and out,
you know, for a few hours,
and if you know anything about London,
you can probably forget it
if you have to drive across the city.
So what he did instead was to go to UC,
which was in the same
neighborhood as the embassy,
but there were no general
relativists there.
So he said, "Well, I'll
work on particle physics."
So he was in his mid-30s,
and starting from scratch in
terms of a whole new area.
And he had a brilliant idea.
And so here is his theory.
His theory is it's not how old you are,
it's how long you've been
thinking about a problem.
So, and that you have 10
years to have a new idea.
And it doesn't matter when you start
as long as you still have
the energy and the time
and make the effort.
And I have to say, I
actually lived through this,
because Francis Crick,
who I mentioned at the very beginning,
changed careers halfway through, right?
He was in his, well, I'm
not sure how old he was,
when he came it was 1977.
Could you calculate that, Rusty?
(laughter)
So he was probably, oh,
I know how old he was,
because he was getting
kicked out of Cambridge.
He was probably 65.
But he wanted to change to neuroscience,
and he realized that it
would be difficult to do that
unless he changed his environment.
And so he had the most amazing
conversations with him,
because he was coming at it as a neophyte,
as someone who doesn't know anything,
and asking these great questions.
And he would have, he would
invite eminent neuroscientists
and neuroanatomists to come
tell him about the visual system
and he spent a couple days
just chatting with them
and it was clear that he was,
had a Socratic dialog that was going on,
and it was really an amazing process,
and I think at the end,
he knew more about the
anatomy of the visual system
than any living person
because of the fact that
he was so omnivorous,
he just wanted to know, he wanted to know.
And didn't get to the finish line.
He picked a really tough
one: consciousness.
And there's a story there, too,
that when he was young, his
mother asked him, you know,
young Francis, "What do you
wanna be when you grow up?"
And he said, "I want to be a scientist."
And his mother said, "Well,
what kind of scientist?"
Well, there's only two questions
that are important enough to study,
and the first one, what is life?
And the second one, what is consciousness?
So he solved the first one,
and then was going on to the second one,
and it illustrates that
it's really important
to ask a good question.
Okay, so we're going to turn it over now
to Carla for the second part.
- Okay, I have a few more questions.
First of all, for Matt State.
Actually, two questions related.
So, come up, come up.
"Why does there seem to be
"an explosion of people with
autism spectrum disorders?"
This is a good question, common question.
The related one is,
"Is there hope for autism to be cured
"by genetic intervention?"
I'll leave them here so you can remember.
- Thank you.
Thanks.
So, first question.
Why does there seem to be an explosion?
There are multiple
explanations for the explosion.
So I think the one that accounts
for the largest proportion of that
has to do with a way
that we've had changes
in diagnosing what autism is,
so we've gone from autism,
which looks very much like the video
that I showed you at
the start of my break,
but over time, over the last 40 years,
the spectrum has expanded considerably,
and so that makes
comparisons to where we were,
even 20 years ago, quite problematic,
and accounts for a very large proportion
of the increase.
The best epidemiological studies suggest
that even when you account for that
that there does appear
to be some true increase
in the rate of autism that
maybe twofold, threefold,
potentially even fourfold
increase in risk,
which is small compared what's
purported to be the change,
but still not at all trivial.
And we don't fully understand that.
I would say that one of
the things that we've found
in our work on de novo mutation
and many other labs have found
is that in fact the rate of
new mutation increase with age,
particularly in fathers,
and anything that increases the potential
for de novo mutation would
then also potentially increase
the rate of risk for autism.
We can quantify that,
and it's quite small,
that contribution of paternal age,
but it opens up a way
of thinking about studying the interaction
of genetic mutation with
environmental inputs
that might give us more of an answer
about why we're seeing increased risk.
So those would be two of the answers.
And then with regard to the prevalence,
and is there a chance for autism
to be cured by genetic intervention?
I think the basis for the
strategy in our laboratory
was to identify genes as a
way of understanding biology
with the thought that if
you can understand biology,
and ultimately, if you
think about it broadly,
how to manipulate that
biology environmentally,
that that was always going to be easier
than trying to change genes.
So the notion is that it's the first step
in understanding something fundamental
that then allows you to
do the kinds of things
that you've seen to intervene
at a different level of analysis,
and we've talked about that a bunch today.
And I think it's certainly not impossible,
now we're being able to both
read and write the genome
in ways that even a few years ago
I would have told you was a long way off,
and we're able to do that.
So there are new technologies
that are allowing us
to manipulate the genome in ways
that are quite surprising.
I do think, though, that ultimately,
it's more likely that these
are gonna lead to interventions
and even potentially cures
by understanding the
process and targeting that
in a way that is more tractable
than trying to get in very early
and change genetic material.
- Thanks, Matt.
Okay, this one is addressed to me,
but I think Mark, you
ought to come up, Bear,
and we should, we can tackle it together.
This is sort of fun.
"What is the potential for increasing
"and directing plasticity
in the adult brain
"to permanently enhance
cognitive function?"
So this would be the cognitive
enhancement question.
- Cognitive enhancers.
Well, there already are
cognitive enhancers, actually.
But I...
It's a very difficult question to address,
because there are many
aspects of cognition
that could be targeted pharmacologically.
One is a process of so-called
memory consolidation,
where the synaptic modifications
that are laid down through experience
themselves have a short lifetime,
unless a process called memory
consolidation comes along
and cements those into place.
And that's a step that we
are already quite aware
that we could target pharmacologically
to make memories last longer.
I will say that, you know,
those of us who've come through this
by studying early developmental plasticity
are very influenced by this
critical period concept,
that is that the brain is immutable,
or parts of the brain,
anyway, are immutable
after a certain age.
I don't think that concept is,
I mean, I think we've
challenged that concept
considerably in the last few years.
So my feeling, and I think
Carla would agree with me,
is that the plasticity is
present in the adult brain.
What's changed is how
readily it's accessed.
And I think we have better understanding
of how to access, gain access
to the plasticity mechanisms.
We're going to find
that the brain's capable
of remarkable plasticity.
- Thanks, Mark.
I think that last point is probably for me
the most salient, that
actually, in the adult brain,
some of these mechanisms that
are present during development
are still there, but
they're kind of braked,
and by figuring out how
to take off the brakes
might be quite a natural way.
Might be dangerous also.
That's the other thing we don't know.
So I have one more,
and it's another one for Catherine Dulac.
And I'm gonna ask her to answer it
because I wanted to ask
you this question, too,
or I maybe had reworded it.
"What characteristics do
you see or expect to see
"in these galanin neurons
to take in mothers, fathers,
"with postpartum depression,
"or another way to put this, really, is,
"can you connect the
galanin neurons in the mice
"to the human condition?"
- So I think what is very interesting
about the position of
these galanin neurons,
they are in this area of the
brain called the hypothalamus,
in this major perioptic area.
And this is an area in
which a number of neurons
have been identified,
different type of neurons,
that each control
something very important,
such as sleep or eating or thirst,
so extremely important function,
and then there is this new set of neurons
that control parenting behavior.
And so what we need to understand, really,
is what regulates the
function of these neurons,
in particular, do they express
particular type of receptors,
receptors to hormones or
receptor to neuropeptides
that could either, that
are involved in either
increasing or decreasing their function.
And so what, we are
doing these studies now,
and if we find ways to manipulate
using small chemicals or neuropeptides,
then this is certainly
something that could be used
or exploited in case of
postpartum depression
or postpartum psychosis.
Obviously, what we would
like to know as well,
or what we should know, try to know,
is what actually is
happening to these neurons
in human condition such
as postpartum depression.
Obviously, it's way more difficult to do.
We would have to use postmortem brains.
But that might be possible.
There are brain banks, and that suddenly,
the relationship between
what's happening in human
and mouse is very interesting.
Thank you for the question.
- Well, thank you, everyone.
Terry, yes?
- I wanna answer the question, too.
- Oh, oh, oh.
I'm not sure, is that okay?
- Actually, this is,
an experiment was done
here at UCSD at the VA,
and it was specifically
with postpartum depression,
and what they did was
they brought the women in,
and they sleep-deprived them,
so that, you know, they
would stay up all night,
or part of the night.
And in the morning, the depression lifted.
And this just seems
bizarre because, you know,
these depressed states often,
they typically last for months and months
and years or forever, right.
It's really a difficult problem.
And, but the flipside was
if they went and took a nap,
even for 10 minutes, their
depression would reoccur.
So you have to choose
between sleep and depression.
But then they did another study,
which was to look at in the brain imaging,
particularly using
activity-dependent FMRI,
and discovered that change in state,
they had actually tracked a
particular part of the cortex
called the anterior cingulate,
which is part of the limbic cortex.
And, interestingly, it was low in women
who had postpartum depression,
and if they stayed up overnight,
the activity would go up,
and by the way, it does
that in normal people, too,
causing a form of euphoria.
So it suggest that there is
something going on there,
it's a circuit problem,
it's not, you know,
that form of depression isn't necessarily
a problem of molecules and synapses.
Maybe it is, but, you know, you can be,
if you can readjust the level of activity
one way or another, you're
gonna help that patient.
And this also led to
experiments by Helen Mayberg,
this is much later, where she stimulated,
put a depth electrode into
the anterior cingulate,
and lo and behold, and these are patients,
either drug, you know,
they weren't able to be treated by drugs
and in some of the patients,
under some circumstances,
you get this very fast flip
where they suddenly, things lift,
and things that were horrible and suicidal
suddenly are getting more normal.
So I think this, I think there are,
there's a real hope, you know.
If we understand the circuit,
we have mechanisms for
going in and rebalancing it
that we might be able to
help some of these patients.
- Yeah, and the last set of studies
was performed on patients with depression,
not postpartum depression, correct?
- [Terry] No, no, yeah, I'm sorry.
- Yeah, just, this was going back
into another interesting and hard topic.
All right, well, I think
that what I'd like to do now
is turn the final part of our day today
over to Rusty Gage, and
he can make final remarks.
And meanwhile, I just wanna
again thank all the speakers
for a wonderful afternoon.
- Thank you, Carla.
(audience applauds)
Okay, so, my role in
this is to thank people.
This is on behalf of making myself,
this has been an experiment for us.
This is our first
symposium in this series,
and I look forward to your response
in determining whether or not
it's been a success or not,
but I think we can see that it is.
Symposia chair, you two, thanks very much
for putting this together
and helping to bring together
a really great group of
speakers on this topic.
Obviously, the speakers.
Thanks for traveling out this
lonely place on the west coast
and the southwest coast
during this time of the year,
but it's great to have you all here.
And, of course, the stalwarts out there
that have stuck out the whole time.
I want to thank the audience very much
for their attendance.
(applause)
And I wanna have a special
thanks to the interpreters,
the ASL interpreters, they've gone,
but we thank them for their help.
KMB staff, in particular, Ingrid, Kate,
Kristen, Linda, Jesse, and Janet,
who have done just an
absolutely terrific job
of putting all this organization together.
So I wanna give them, please.
Okay.
(applause)
Kent is up there and has been helping
throughout the time with videos,
and many of you come in contact with him,
but also Rich, Matt, Marci, and Jacob
have been outstanding
in the filming category,
so thank them as well, please.
(applause)
And finally, to keep you,
we'll be able to watch
this again, or better yet,
get your colleagues, your relatives,
to have a look at this.
And take your time and see it again,
and get some of those
pieces of the material
that you didn't get before.
And so try to join us next
year for the next one,
and we look forward to
any suggestions and topics
that we could handle.
Thank you all.
(applause)
(upbeat music)